If you've ever been in a car dealership,
browsing for cars, you'll probably hear
a salesperson ask you the question, "How
much per month are you looking to
spend?" And if you've never bought a car
before or know how the car buying game
works, you answer pretty honestly and
you might say something like, "I'm happy
if I pay between $500 to $600 a month."
The moment you reveal your number
though, you've lost the game and you've
actually cost yourself upwards of
thousands of dollars. You see, there are
many ways to finance a car, but if you
negotiate based on the monthly payment
number, you're allowing the dealer to
rearrange every variable in the deal for
their benefit. The price, the loan term,
the interest rate, and add-ons, they all
can get shifted so that your payment
looks the same at the end of the day,
but on the back end, you're actually
paying a lot more. I'm going to give you
some examples of how they do this and
then we're going to also discuss what to
focus on instead when you go and buy a
car. So, let's say you're in that
dealership and you've already revealed
that your upper limit is $600 a month.
The car you're looking at retails for
$27,000, so something like this Subaru
Crosstrek, which the MSRP is $26,995.
The estimated monthly payment here if
you finance the entire price of the car,
so no money down, is $528 a month,
assuming you finance it for 5 years at a
6.5% interest rate. So, that's right in
your budget range of $500 to $600 a
month and that's actually closer to the
lower bound. And the problem is is that
if you don't do any research on your car
buying ahead of time, what the dealer
can do is pretty sneaky. They might
steer you towards a higher priced trim
or perhaps add products like a dealer
package with tinted windows and floor
mats that you didn't really ask for. And
they're going to do all this to try to
steer you towards a $600 a month payment
as much as possible because that's what
you stated your upper bound was. They're
not going to tell you that you were
already under budget at the listed price
initially. So, the entire sales process
here is designed to keep you focused on
the monthly payment instead of the total
cost of the car. So, let's look at the
four-square worksheet as an
illustration. This is a worksheet that a
dealer might show you. It has four
quadrants, the trade-in value in the top
left, the vehicle price in the top
right, the down payment and your monthly
payment. It looks pretty straightforward
and if you're looking at this from a car
buying perspective, your eyes probably
go straight to the vehicle price in the
top right. And that would be pretty
logical, that's pretty much all that
matters, right? However, what the dealer
wants you to focus on is the monthly
payment number in the bottom right,
which in this particular example is way
too high. This worksheet as is looks
really simple because there's only four
numbers on it right now, but as
negotiations start to progress, they
might start crossing out certain numbers
and replacing them with others, changing
your loan length and your down payment
in order to get you to a lower monthly
payment and by the end of it, your
worksheet might look like something like
this. Notice in the bottom right
quadrant that your monthly payment was
$845
a month for 36 months, but somehow it
dropped to $476 by the end of the
negotiation. But if you look at the
vehicle price, it doesn't really move
that much. It went from maybe $34,000
OTD or out the door to $33,980.
In this case, by looking at the sheet,
it looks like the loan terms just got
extended, but it doesn't really mean you
saved that much money on the price of
the car in reality. Now, dealerships
might not have this exact four-square
worksheet, but they're going to have
some sort of version of it. So, perhaps
a deal sheet, a printout, or they turn a
screen towards you and the goal is
always the same, to try to get you to
think about the monthly payment. It also
doesn't help that this deal sheet is
probably presented to you after being at
the dealership for already a few hours.
So, that means you're already mentally
fatigued, you just want to drive the car
home, and you're more likely to agree to
something that you might not have wanted
originally. A second way that
dealerships can use your budget against
you is simply by marking up the interest
rate on your car loan when you apply for
financing through their dealer. In fact,
this is really well documented. There
have been lawsuits against automakers
for interest rate discrimination like
this case from 2015 against Honda. The
DOJ reached a settlement with Honda
because they were engaging in a pattern
of discrimination against minorities
when it came to auto lending rates. Now,
the discrimination is one thing and
obviously not very good, but if you read
this press release, the fascinating part
is just how it outlines how standard of
a business practice marking up interest
rates are. So, I quote, "Honda has
agreed to change the way it prices its
loans by limiting dealer markup to 125
basis points or 1.25% for loans of 60
months or less and to 100 basis points
or about 1% for loans greater than 60
months." And if you read further on in
the release, it states that Honda, like
most other major auto lenders, lets the
dealer change your interest rate from
what you actually qualified for. That
means that dealerships just have the
discretion to charge you more for their
own gain. So, let's say you qualify for
a 6.5% interest rate on the $27,000 car
from earlier, the Subaru. The dealer
might come back to you and say,
"Congrats, you've been approved for a
7.5% interest rate." And you think to
yourself, "Well, I think that's the
going rate right now." But if you were
to actually do some research and you
know that by taking an extra 1% interest
rate on that loan, you're paying an
extra $764
in interest over the course of that loan
and your monthly payment is now higher
as well. Now, that's just a 1% interest
rate hike. Some dealers can mark up your
interest rates even more by up to 1.5 to
2.5 percentage points. Now, true story,
I actually went to a Toyota dealership
over the weekend this past weekend to
help my friend with her car and the
financing rates that they had for cars
were astronomically high. They were
between 6.9 to 8.9 to even up to 9.9%.
On bigger loans, that can add up to
thousands of dollars of interest and
you'd never know this if you didn't do
any research ahead of time. All right,
so what should you do instead? I have
five actionable steps that you can take
before you go and step foot into any car
dealership that's going to save you a
lot of money. The key here is that you
need to spend about 30 minutes prepping
before you walk into any dealership.
Knowing some basics about your own
financial situation as well as what a
car should go for and the interest rates
will save you thousands of dollars. The
first step is to know what you can
actually afford before you walk into the
dealer. So, in our example conversation
from the beginning of this video, I said
you might walk into a dealership and say
that your budget is between $500 and
$600 per month. If you say a range like
that instead of an exact number, that's
a signal to me that you don't know your
exact number, and you should really know
what that exact number that you can
afford on a monthly basis is. A good
rule of thumb to follow is the 24/10 car
buying rule. That's where you put at
least 20% down on a car, you finance a
car for no more than 4 years, and you
make sure that your total monthly car
costs, that's your payment plus your
insurance, it doesn't exceed 10% of your
gross monthly income. So, if you make
$84,000 a year, that's $7,000 in gross
income per month. Therefore, your total
car costs should be under $700 a month
as an example. Some people find this
really difficult, so they stretch the
car loan to 5 years instead of 4, and
that can make it more tolerable.
However, just know that if a car doesn't
fit your math on a 4 or a 5-year loan,
it's probably too much of a car for you
financially. Once you know what you can
actually afford, step two is that you
should look into financing options in
terms of loans before you go into the
dealership. In the real estate world,
you can get pre-approved for a loan
before you buy a house, and you can
actually do the same thing in the car
world as well. If you go to your bank or
your credit union or even an online
lender, you can apply for a pre-approval
letter on a car loan of say $27,000.
Banks will then tell you what you
qualify for and what their interest
rates that they can offer you on that
type of loan are. This actually gives
you a lot of negotiating leverage
because it's going to signal to the
dealer that you're a really serious
buyer. You have your baseline interest
rate to compare against the dealer's
financing offers. And a common
misconception is that people think that
they have to go with the dealer's
financing options for their interest
rates, but really you can go with any
lender that gives you a loan. The way
that this logistically works, if you're
curious, is that the title of the car is
going to list the lender as the lien
holder. You're the registered owner of
the car when you buy it, but the lender
has the legal claim on the car until the
loan is paid off. The lien holder in
this case can be the dealership that's
offering you financing, or it can be
your bank or your credit union. The
other perk about getting a pre-approval
is that it streamlines the process at
the dealership. So, a good amount of
time that you're going to spend in the
dealership is going to be talking about
financing. Doing any groundwork before
you get to the dealer will end up saving
you a lot of time as well as any
headaches. Step number three, and this
is probably one of the most important,
is that if a salesman ever asks you what
monthly payment you're looking for or
what your monthly budget is, you really
just want to counter them with, "I don't
really care much about the monthly
payment. I'm just more focused on the
overall price." If you say that, that's
going to help a lot, and if they ever
try high sales pressure tactics on you,
you just want to say you're not ready to
purchase today yet, and you want some
time to think about it. You basically
want to intentionally slow down the
process if you feel things are moving
too fast or they're trying to use
urgency tactics against you. You can
always negotiate over email or text, and
if you're really interested in the car,
just know that you don't have to commit
to it right then and there. I think a
lot of people just go to the car
dealership and expect, "Okay, I'm going
to get a car today, and I just want to
get this task off of my list, and I
don't really want to come back to this
place again." But, if you can exercise
some patience and you're able to set
some limits for yourself and know that
you can go back in any time or to any
other dealership and get the same or
similar car that you've been looking
for, it's still going to be there for
you. Step number four is to keep your
car loan to 60 months max. With the
average new car loan these days being
between 69 to 72 months long, dealers
are going to try to get you to these
longer loan terms as well. But, the
longer the loan gets, the more interest
you're going to pay, and there's a
second problem, which is that on a
longer loan, you're at risk of being
underwater, which means that you
technically owe more on the car than
it's actually worth. So, if you need to
sell or the car gets totaled, you're
paying out of pocket to cover that
difference. And step number five is to
handle add-ons separately or just say no
to them all together. You just don't
want them being lumped in together with
your total purchase price. When I
personally bought a car before and the
price has already been negotiated upon,
you get to the finance manager's office,
and that's basically where they try to
sell you the second list of items, which
is usually extended warranties, paint
protection, wheel protection, fabric
coating, gap insurance, and whatever
else they can roll into the loan. When
you get to that finance manager's
department, you just really want to say
no to almost everything that they try to
upsell you on. One exception might be
gap insurance. This is basically when,
let's say, you owe $20,000 on a car, but
the car might be only worth $15,000 if
it's totaled. That gap insurance will
pay the remaining difference if your car
ever gets into a pretty bad accident.
But even with gap insurance, you can
decline to get it from the car
dealership and just call different auto
insurance companies and get it yourself
instead. And if you really want the
extended warranty, I would just say
don't buy it right then and there,
especially when you're buying the car
with all that added pressure. That's
something you can definitely wait on,
you can think about it, and decide to
buy it later if you really want it. All
right, so the next time you walk into a
car dealership, if you've watched this
video and prepared yourself, you will be
ready to go toe-to-toe with them and get
the best deal possible. Some resources
that you can look into in order to get
as prepared as possible is to check out
the edmunds.com car forums,
cargurus.com, and any other websites
that I will link down below in the
description. Let me know what you
thought of this video in the comments
and share your car buying experiences
down there as well, and I'll see you
guys in the comment section or in the
next video. All right, peace.